that's why I've launched the five big
questions to hear from as many people
from society as possible I'm really
pleased that over 200,000 people have
already filled in the survey but is not
too late to have your say that's Kate
Middleton making a rare plea to her
Instagram followers the Duchess of
Cambridge took to Instagram on Monday to
make one final push for citizens of the
UK to fill out her early childhood
survey after making promotional stops in
Wales Northern Ireland Scotland and
England where she met with local parents
grandparents and caregivers to learn
more about what's needed to provide and
support the next generation of youth
parents and families and carers at the
heart of raising the next generation and
that's why I felt so passionate about
listening to them and listening to your
thoughts and your views and how best we
can support you going forward Kate also
recently stopped by Giovanna Fletcher's
happy mum happy baby podcast if I take
the Express of my own childhood couples
with what I know now what I have learnt
from the experts and the audio sector I
think there's a few things that really
stand out for me one is quality of
relationships in an episode released on
Saturday the mom of three opens up about
the impact of her own early childhood
experiences amazing granny who devoted a
lot of time for us playing with us in
doing arts and crafts and going to green
house doing gardening stuff and cooking
with us am I trying to incorporate a lot
of the experiences that she gave us at
the time into the experiences that I
give my children now and she shared this
sweet story about her 4 year old
daughter Charlotte I got this one photo
Charlotte's many a blue belt I just it
really for me moments like that mean so
much to me as parent and I try every day
to put moments like that and even if
there's more even if yeah we don't I
don't have time but that in an ideal
world is what I'd like to do asset of
great relationships
and happy environments and experiences
meanwhile Kate's hubby Prince William
has been busy promoting his own mental
health campaign in collaboration with
the Football Association he tells about
a bit the heads up campaign and and it
seems it's been a season-long campaign
and the idea being that we'd get people
to talk about myself kick off a
conversation one of the sort of last
bastions of maleness that seem to be
quite difficult to reach and felt like
the football community and we felt that
there was an awful lot of opportunity
here William teamed up with Aston
Villa's John McGinn to kick off what he
hopes will be the biggest conversation
ever on mental health once she starts to
be on fitness you'll want to go to the
gym we want to stay fit well why don't
we do the same with our heads you
mentally fit as well of course the
Royals have dedicated the last few years
to D stigmatizing mental health
why has he doesn't want mental health
it's a corny Fred Wilson mental health
sort of seem to run between different
areas we were working in 2016
William and Kate along with Harry
launched the heads together campaign
which partners with charities to change
the national conversation on mental
well-being if you can have a family
environment where you can talk openly
about your issues that makes for a
better family better preparation
probably working better job doing better
at school every day you know so just
goes on and on
[Music]